since the start of the pandemic care
homes say they've been crying out for
more support and resources and it's
still needed I hear that there is the
shield around care homes we still are
not able to to say that we can see or
feel that shield in an interview with
Sky News the Justice Secretary admitted
NHS patients had been the government's
focus in testing for coronavirus we did
decide to focus upon the NHS I think the
issue with care homes is that we've got
many thousands of different providers
different settings there been lots of
examples of care homes that have
mercifully stayed infection free but
sadly far too many cases of infection
and then death lairs Luckman is the
spokesman for 350 providers in
Birmingham and says he's surprised to
hear such an admission I think it's
refreshing to hear them finally come up
with what the strategy was I think it's
something that we've all felt and seen
for ourselves that Care Homes was a
second thought in this pandemic and
denying that he wasn't a second thought
I think was a bit laughable for us in
the sector so now that they've actually
knowledged the problem what we would
like to know is what they're going to do
about it care homes say the Justice
Secretary's comment is significant
probably the first time that we've had
an admission that there was a priority
for the NHS we knew that from the very
start of the pandemic and in fact part
of our challenge was that the priority
to the NHS led to things like the
disruption of the PPE supplies for care
homes Sky News first spoke to Kathy
Gardner last week revealing her anger
over government policies put in place at
the start of the outbreak which allowed
patients who've had coronavirus to be
sent back to care homes with outter
tests showing they're clear Kathy's 88
year-old father Michael died in a care
home in April the collateral damage is
there to see and the policies are there
to see I just keep going back to the
dates of when
these policies and guidelines were
issued and what the government knew at
the time they can't pretend they didn't
know the risk to care homes they
absolutely did know the risk at the
daily briefing NHS England defended
testing policies I'm absolutely sure
that my medical colleagues would not be
discharging patients under any
circumstances unless they were sure that
their medical treatments in hospital was
complete they were fit for discharge and
it was safe to discharge them in spite
of the admission of one Minister many
care homes say greater support is still
needed if they're to keep vulnerable
people in care home safe Lisa Holland
Sky News Birmingham